hey everybody it's Charlie you've all
been requesting a video for Thanos as
black order during infinity war and
Avengers 4 we don't know as much about
what's going on with them during
Avengers 4 just because of their art
during infinity war being so close to
the comic book arc that they had during
the infinity saga so most of you
probably know that they're combining a
couple different comic book arcs for the
next two Avengers films so I'll try to
explain those tube because some of the
characters weren't involved at all in
the original Infinity Saga during the
1970s which is where most of the plot is
coming from but some of the other ones
didn't have anything to do with the more
recent infinity saga so I'll try to
explain the differences in the comic
book changes they've made to all the
children of Thanos in these comic book
arcs but if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the Marvel videos and there is a new
round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
going on all I know it's a new winner at
the end of this so children to Thanos
this is probably the best look that
we've had at them we've gotten a couple
trailer shots
I'll explain where they pop up during
the trailers but this is Corvus glaive
his wife Proxima midnight
evany mah and then Coll obsidian so you
don't totally remember the comic book
arc that they came from they've actually
already changed collab Sid Ian's name
his name is black dwarf in the comics
you can imagine why I'd isni might want
to change his name a little bit just
because mbaku
during black panthers name is really man
ape and Disney was like you're crazy if
you think we're gonna go anywhere close
to that name so black dwarf is now coal
obsidian but coal obsidian in the comics
is actually the name of the team itself
some of you have noticed that they're
missing a couple team members on the
roster so they're super giant and then
later Black Swan joins the team so if
you're wondering why they cut those
characters one there's already like way
too many characters and infinity war so
they just needed to find a way to
simplify it a little bit and supergiant
in the comics reads a lot like nebula so
when they have really crazy movies like
this with these big action scenes like
you see that will kind of fight see they
try to have the characters look
relatively distinct so you can tell
who's fighting who these actual fighters
themselves debuted during Avengers
infinity which was an arc that happened
just a couple years ago not during the
original Infinity Saga back during the
1970s so they are one of the biggest
changes but they wanted to give Thanos
his children and
sort of like a dark version of The
Avengers to go after the infinity gems
and that's what they did during their
comic book art they were really just his
lieutenants that he recruited from
across the galaxy the worst of the worst
compared to the Avengers who were
supposed to be the best of the best
they've been using Gamora nebulas art
during the last two movies to set this
idea of fantasies children up no
politics bore me the demeanor is that of
a pouty child and apparently you
alienated my favorite daughter
so during Gardens the galaxy 2 Nebula
goes on this big rant about what
happened to her when she was a child why
she looks so mechanical every time my
sister prevailed
my father would replace a piece of me
with machinery claiming he wanted me to
be her equal but she won again and again
and again
never once refraining so after I murder
my sister I will bow worship with every
conceivable instrument of death I will
hunt my father like a dog and I will
tear him apart slowly piece by piece
until he knows some semblance of the
profound and unceasing pain I know every
single
so within that there are shades of that
original infinity saga with a nose so
during the really classic 70s story she
was one of the critical people that took
the gauntlet from Thanos because she had
been so mistreated all he cares about is
getting death to love him that's his
whole reason for balancing the universe
so to speak killing all these people so
when an opportunity presents itself
nebula takes the gauntlet from him and
is ready to exact her revenge but
eventually Adam warlock has to get the
gauntlet off so nebula goes crazy in her
mission to destroy Thanos which you see
a little bit of her during the trailer
and technically she is part of the
guardians of the galaxy by the end of
vol 2 so even though she hates the
out of all these characters I'm still
calling her a good character during the
next two Avengers films she'll help them
fight Thanos and their other children
but as you can see all these other
children did not leave that as they're
still loyal to him and they've all been
constantly upgraded but the reason why
they look different is because Thanos
took them from all their homes and I
know you don't see any Chitauri here but
he conquered the Chitauri that's why
they're his army like he easily just
mopped the floor with all their generals
so starting with Corvus glaive in the
infinity war trailer you see him in
Proxima midnight going for vision in the
mind gem you see Captain America Falcon
Black Widow and Scarlet Witch try to
protect him it seems like they're fairly
successful because you see them all
collectively walking into the New
Avengers facility none the worse for
wear but as his name implies Corvus
glaive wields that special glaive it can
cut the skin of the Hulk it can cleave
atoms in half and as long as the glaive
survives he cannot be killed
Wolverine style so like if there's a
single piece of one of his bones lying
nearby but the glaive still exists he'll
reconstitute himself so I have a feeling
that we'll get to see a version of that
during the film like someone will kill
him but the glaive will survive there
will be some sort of surprise
moment where he comes back now I don't
know if he's gonna be married to Proxima
midnight in the movie because it's gonna
be over so quickly so a lot of times
they'll just simplify their backstories
they might all just be children of
Thanos but as you can see she looks
heavily modified like nebula I don't
think that she's from the same race as
nebula even though they have that same
blue skin but the spear that she wields
was forged by
a nose from a son trapped in distorted
space-time so it acts is sort of like a
supernova and a Sun at the same time so
it gives off this crazy energy and she
can control its relative density
[Music]
so you have to imagine her throwing a
spear they can also increase its mass to
that of a black hole but it's still the
same size as a regular spear so like
when she throws it at Captain America
here it is a little silly that he's able
to catch it like that but they want it
to be a badass moment technically if she
were to increase its mass the way that
it's allowed to in the comics he would
just be obliterated by even getting
close to the tip of that spear but on
top of that they also lace the blade of
the spear with this crazy toxin that can
poison the Hulk so like you have to
imagine that pretty much any of the
children of Thanos are strong enough or
have an ability that can kill or maim
any of the Avengers no matter how strong
they are it's just that in the comics
some of their abilities were tailored to
fight certain Avengers like I said
Corvus glaive glaive can cut the skin of
the Hulk so obviously he was intended to
bite the Hulk but any of the children of
Thanos have special abilities on par
with any of the other Avengers
evany Maz powers a little more about
magic and mental persuasion which is why
Fano sends him after Doctor Strange in
the time gem because you send a magician
to fight a magician like that funny
scene with Loki during Ragnarok you have
to imagine that evany Maas powers are on
par with that thank you very much to go
home you think it's some kind of sorcery
don't think for one minute you
second-rate
that's why you see his feet walking
across all these bodies is a little hard
to tell if these are the Asgardians or
these are the people at the sanctum
because he will be going for the time
gem at the sanctum colab Citian kind of
looks like Thanos his version of the
Hulk you see him fighting in this big
Wakanda seen here I'm sure there's gonna
be some crazy cool obsidian versus the
Hulkbuster or the hope during that
though you just can't put two giant
creatures in a film like that and not
smash them together it's gonna be so
much fun
he wields a giant hammer and he does
have his normal intellect level it's not
like Banner and the Hulk where some of
his intelligence gets drained out the
more powerful the hole gets but I think
the chatty version of the Hulk that
we've started to get in the movies is
more evidence that they're sort of
merging the banner and Hulk
personalities there's lots of rumors
about the Hulk during the next two films
but we can speculate about that in
different videos for the most part
pretty simple backstory for them in the
film though Thanos conquers worlds over
his lifetime he takes tributes these
children were part of those tributes
Gamora left because she realized how
evil he was nebula left because she
cared about her sister and because she
was so abused so slightly different
reasons but same result
nebula hates Thanos more than Gamora
does if you're wondering about that
Gamora is still Thanos his favorite
daughter he feels the sting of her
betrayal they will address that during
the film but post all your theories in
the comments below like who is your
favorite member of the black order right
now and what'll happen is there's a
bunch more Marvel videos that I'm
working on this week but congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner pro floppy
disk please private message me so I can
get your contact details click here for
brand new infinity war and click here
for brand new flash thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]